[Musique]
même si ça ce n'est donnerait on entre
chez lui on ne peut s'empêcher de se
jouer une autre note à ce fameux rock
signé en 1976 pour la messe du temps
présent de béjart bienvenue chez le
grand vizir de la musique concrète qui
le grand papa de la techno
[Musique]
et on recommence que vous réagissez
contre les gens parlent de vous comme le
pape de la musique techno et de la
musique répétitive assez mal parce que
trente journées au début d'un mouvement
au début de quelque chose tout à fait
important on se dit 50 ans après six
reprises s'est standardisée ça devient
une opération presque commercial
bien sûr c'est un fait sociologique très
important mais moi je tiens encore à mes
vieilles recettes à mes manipulation à
ce que j'ai trouvé pour que les sons
soit inouïe et se développent et
deviennent les bruits deviennent des
nouveaux astronomique de partout ils
viennent jusqu'à cette petite maison tu
en plus du son du 12e arrondissement
pour les plus grands dj il est le père
spirituel
l'année dernière déjà lui ont rendu
hommage en remixant là mais ce dernier
jugement du maître
c'était pas mal mais que j'aurais
peut-être préféré faire le remisage web
[Musique]
et on rit le pionnier visionnaire et
merveilles les enfants de la télé que
nous sommes et oui en 1970 s'il n'y
avait pas que les chats d'offres qui
travaillait pour le werther
[Musique]